[Musique]
après la rentrée les évaluations depuis
cinq ans en septembre les élèves de cp
bûche en français et en mathématiques
18000 yvelinois les ont passées jusqu'au
23 septembre des héros à quatre pattes
cinq chiens des pompiers des yvelines
ont été récompensé d'un trophée ils sont
capables de détecter des maladies comme
le co lead les technologies du numérique
se met au service des collectivités
territoriales une matinée de conférences
s'est tenue autour de la thématique
bâtir des territoires de confiance au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines trois thématiques pour la
protection économique des entreprises la
gendarmerie des yvelines le medef et la
cgpme organisé cette semaine des
ateliers auprès d'une cinquantaine de
chefs d'entreprise les incendiaires du
chapiteau de chanteloup les vignes sont
devant la justice depuis le 22 septembre
une audience quasiment deux ans après
les faits le lieu culturel s'est
embrasée lors de scènes de violences
urbaines le 26 septembre ce sont les
virades de l'espoir un événement profit
de l'association vaincre la
mucoviscidose
des animations sont notamment prévus à
saint germain en laye 25 premiers
comités locaux au tour de karl olive une
quinzaine de maires et d'élus hubinois
soutiennent emmanuel macron leur
objectif être source de propositions
pour le programme de l'actuel président
de la république et fédérer les soutiens
sur le terrain
pas